let's talk about the worst food for the
heart okay
now this is even worse than sugar but
Sugar's still bad for the heart believe
me now some of you are probably thinking
it's definitely the omega-6 fatty acids
right like the soil oil the corn oil
those oils and you're absolutely right
that would be even you know comparable
to sugar if not worse but there's
something else that's even a worse
version of these omega-6 fatty acids and
that would be
the trans fats now you're probably
saying yourself well I thought they'd
banned them didn't they you don't see
trans fats anymore in the food supply
but the FDA in 2015 no longer classifies
them as generally recognized as safe
okay because they
cost some slight minor complications and
it's taken years and years and years and
years to recognize the fact that these
trans fats are really really bad for the
arteries it majorly increases the risk
for heart attack
stroke type 2 diabetes insulin
resistance cancer it increases LDL and
decreases your HDL it creates
inflammatory problems it's been linked
to autoimmune diseases infertility and
even tendon and Bone degeneration but
other than that it's pretty safe now
typically when we think of trans fats we
think of the partially hydrogenated oils
okay
so let me just kind of explain simply of
how they make these so you start off
with an unsaturated fat most of the time
like soy oil or corn oil and then you
heat this thing under high Heats over a
period of time so it goes through this
phase it becomes thicker right so you
have this partially hydrogenated version
okay it's altering the chemistry this is
an artificial new thing and the
personally hydrogenated oils have the
trans fats and then if you leave it in
longer it becomes fully hydrogenated and
apparently at that stage you don't see
the trans fats now that does not mean
it's healthier it creates a lot of other
problems I'm like how could you go
through this process and have it being
really bad and all of a sudden if you
leave it longer it'll become healthier
so when you read any label and you see
partially hydrogenated or hydrogenated
you know you need to avoid it but you're
making this kind of liquid into a salad
and they use this in pie crust and
popcorn and cookies and crackers and
croutons I mean it's all over and so
industry is adapted to this and they're
definitely lowering the amount of trans
fats which is good but
it comes with the package which we'll
talk about but you should know that
every increase of trans fats by two
percent in your diet you dramatically
increase the risk of getting a heart
attack or actually dying a heart attack
by like 20 to 35 percent so it's really
really bad for your heart because it
kind of it becomes part of your cells
it's no longer fluid your arteries
become rigid and hardened I mean you're
introducing this very unnatural
substance into the body and at one time
they said these hydrogenated Foods were
to replace the saturated fats that were
really really bad like they were
healthier than saturated fats the only
reason they did this is to increase
shelf life now you can take this
unsaturated oil and you don't have to
keep it in the refrigerator anymore
right it's completely changed and it
just lasts for a long period of time now
the interesting thing about this FDA
claim is it doesn't include animal feeds
right like animal food even pet food or
you know the chicken feed the poultry
feed or feed for other animals so you
could be getting these trans fats
indirectly by eating animals who have
been fed these trans fats they don't
even know they're getting it it's not
even labeled as hydrogenated oils and
this is the problem you don't really
always know what you're getting and so
when you see something that says
encapsulated citric acid okay and you'd
probably see this you know in 99 of all
the beef sticks some of the sausages out
there and what that is is a combination
of citric acid and hydrogenated
vegetable oils which include trans fats
and I will say this I like to consume
some of these beef sticks and one that I
found that's pretty good that does not
contain these trans fats this
encapsulated citric acid
is the Rome sticks and just to remind
people I'm not affiliated with this
company I get no Kickbacks or anything I
just recommend good products when I find
them and I will put a link down below
the other thing is that if you go to any
fast food restaurant or you know even a
regular restaurant chances are you're
going to be getting some of these trans
fats and they can accumulate in your
body but there's something else I want
to talk about it's a loophole that
industry uses because of the creation of
a definition of zero trans fats you're
allowed to have 0.5 a half of a gram
500 milligrams of trans fats in one
serving size to be able to claim that it
has zero trans fats
So when you buy these products to say
zero trans fats it doesn't really mean
zero trans fats and this is just so
logical and let's look at this for a
second right you have Ruffles potato
chips right very delicious one serving
size is basically two tablespoons of
these potato chips so Ruffles potato
chips claims to have zero trans fats
right and if you're like me
there's no way you can just consume two
tablespoons which is one serving of
Ruffles potato chips more likely you're
going to consume the whole bag and
that's what I would do so if you're
eating the whole bag you're going to be
consuming a lot of trans fats despite
it's saying zero trans fats on the label
now Western price foundation uh worked
with I think it was the University of
Illinois to do some testing on some
foods in the grocery store to measure
how much trans fats are really in these
foods and so with Ruffles potato chips
they found preserving size there were
3.7 milligrams of trans fats per gram of
all the different fats but that's just
for one serving size right if we
multiply that by the number of serving
size that really adds up Ritz crackers
on the label trans fats are zero the
serving size is 16 grams and Western
price found when they did a testing
51.9 milligrams now with the Hostess
Donuts which I'm sure you've eaten
before which have zero trans fats a
serving size of 57 at 20.9 milligrams
per serving size I mean I don't know
about you but can you just eat that one
little donut I can't I have to eat
multiple donuts and then we have like
Crisco shortening this is interesting
because Crisco shortening has been known
for these trans fats right so they had
to go back to their chemistry and really
kind of redo the numbers and figure this
out and reduce the serving size and also
reduce their chemistry to reduce the
amount of trans fats but of course what
are they replacing that with more
saturated fats and so the way that
industry has been coping with this is
probably by reducing their serving size
to really make sure that they fit the
definition of zero trans fats which is
0.5 grams but they also have to replace
these trans fats with something else and
they've been replacing them with
saturated fats now some of that maybe
came from palm oil
but that's also replaced with artificial
saturated fats right and that would be
the hydrogenated the fully hydrogenated
oils that are not the partially
hydrogenated they don't have trans fats
in there but hydrogenated oils are like
plastic they're just very very hardened
and your body does not do well on them
either just with one serving size of
Crisco they found the trans fats were
not zero they're like 11.9 milligrams
per serving size then you get the
margarine called favorite margin they
don't claim to have zero but it's 1.5
grams but check this out when they
evaluated the true amounts of trans fats
they found
116.8 milligrams per serving size now
you have to realize that just because
they reduce the amount of trans fats
okay in these foods and even they
replace it with saturated fats and
probably mostly artificial they're still
made from these omega-6 fatty acids
which are normally
um GMO right we have the soy the canola
the corn oil the cottonseed oil and
these are all heated and oxidized in
they use solvents with them and they've
been known to create a lot of problems
and inflammation in your body and so you
just need to read labels be aware of
what you're eating when you go to
restaurants you know really make sure
you order things that have no potential
for having these trans fats like even
the croutons right that you eat who
knows but these things can accumulate
they can affect your heart they can
affect your liver and you know I really
feel for the institutional food as well
because there's no requirements for
trans fats for those foods that that
would be the foods in the school system
in hospitals and nursing homes daycare
centers I mean you can just imagine like
going to the hospital right the place
that you're you're trying to get healthy
and uh you exposure to all the the
different uh microbes and sick people
and then the food on top of that with
the trans fats and the omega-6 fatty
acids which are highly inflammatory even
though it might not be trans fats so I
hope you're a little bit more aware of
these Foods so you can avoid them and
replace them with healthier fats and I'm
talking about healthy saturated fats and
by the way saturated fats are healthy if
they come from animals that are
grass-fed the grain-fed animals are
going to be more inflammatory but the
fat that normally comes with the protein
in nature is natural and they've never
should have been replaced by the
saturated fats and especially promoted
as that being something healthier and
since most heart problems start with
inflammation on the inside of your
arteries you should probably know more
about tocatrinals which is a protective
vitamin E against that problem and I put
that video up right here check it out